no matter where you are located almost
all of your internet data is transmitted
through a hidden network of undersea
cables in fact 97 of all internet
traffic runs through this hidden
infrastructure of thousands of miles of
fiber optic cables that zigzag our ocean
floors with our dependence on the
internet increasing by the day modern
life is totally reliant on these
sub-aquatic wires but how do they work
and what is the future of internet
communications also how is it possible
that your internet connection is almost
always there don't these cables get
destroyed by ships and sharks in today's
video let us explore the depths and find
out how the internet travels across
oceans the idea of transmitting signals
through wires by connecting two land
masses separated by an ocean is not new
the first ever undersea cable was laid
in 1850 between britain and france later
in 1958 the atlantic ocean was bridged
it is hard to imagine that we are still
essentially using the same concept even
after 170 years these undersea cables
are laid down by specialized ships
called cable layers that hold thousands
of miles of coiled cables on their decks
after charting a safe path avoiding
fishing zones anchoring areas fault
lines and other potential dangers these
ships navigate the course and slowly
uncoil cable onto the ocean's surface
buoys are used to keep the cables
floating once the operators are
satisfied and the weather is right they
cut the buoys and allow the cables to
sink to the ocean floor underwater
technicians will follow its progress to
make sure that the cables do not get
tangled and are being laid in the right
place according to the submarine cable
map of the world as of 2021 over 436
sub-sea cable systems have been laid
criss-crossing all the major oceans and
seas combined that's over 800 000 miles
of under-seat cables operational today
twice the distance between our earth and
the moon but these are obviously not the
same types of cables used a century ago
the modern subsea cables on which our
wireless world rests are specifically
designed to carry large amounts of data
packets over long distances these cables
are rarely much wider than a garden hose
but at their core are many individual
fiber optic threads each carrying
billions of bits of information per
second the fiber optics are sheathed in
various layers of silicon plastic steel
wiring copper and mylar the design is
optimized to provide insulation to the
signal and protect the cable from damage
from weather man-made or natural events
or even wildlife yes you heard that
right ocean wildlife like sharks gnawing
on a cable can cause major damage and it
has happened before to some of google's
cables so you know i can't help but
think a shark eating through cables
would be a better game than chrome's
jumping dinosaur although by far the
most common cause of cable damage is
accidental human activities such as
fishing vessels or ships dragging their
anchors along the ocean beds damage to
these cables can be caused by
intentional human activity as well like
sabotage during times of conflict or by
transnational terrorism activities
however such incidents are historically
rare but do not worry your family
whatsapp group is in no danger companies
that operate these cables follow a
safety and numbers approach spreading
their networks over multiple cables that
way if one breaks it doesn't bring down
the whole network with it anyways we
digress let us get back to the cables
the fiber optic threads are the secret
sauce that makes these underground
cables so successful the theory
governing this technology is known as
total internet reflection similar to the
way light is reflected between two glass
surfaces data signals are beamed down
these sub c cables using the same
principle and lasers when the lasers
from one end hit the glass fibers it is
reflected back up the length of the
cable traveling toward the receptors at
the other end of the cable this process
is repeated over and over again at
staggering speeds maintaining the global
chain of communications and by bundling
many fiber optic threads together in one
cable this form of data transmission can
handle enormous amounts of traffic all
at once so how fast are these undersea
modern cables you might wonder well the
recently installed maria transatlantic
undersea cable which became operational
in 2018 is capable of carrying 224
terabytes of information per second
along its eight fiber optic pairs as if
this was not impressive enough facebook
or rather meta announced in late 2021
that it is contracting japanese
information technology giant nec to make
a transatlantic cable capable of
transmitting at 0.5 petabytes per second
that is 500 terabytes or 500 000
gigabytes per second facebook is also
working on the largest subsea cable
project in the world connecting 33
countries in africa the middle east and
europe called to africa it will stretch
45 000 kilometers connecting three
different continents and has a design
capacity of up to 180 terabytes per
second at launch similarly google has
also recently confirmed its high-speed
subsea cable project equiano which will
run from portugal to south africa
connecting nigeria along the way of
course this does not mean that you the
end user will get this speed anytime
soon but it would definitely allow your
internet service provider to up their
game and offer even faster speeds and
more reliable connections speaking of
providers let us look at the owners of
these massive networks of undersea
infrastructures that literally run our
world in the early days of the internet
existing undersea cable networks were
already owned and operated by major
telecom carriers at t and bt so they
would lease out bandwidth to other
players in the market the decade of 1990
saw a major boom in the industry
undersea cables began to attract
investment from private companies as the
entire world slowly digitized itself
these companies specializing in
underwater cable technology saw the
potential of huge profits and started
selling capacity to telecom companies
whose traffic demands were soaring
through the roof in the last two decades
the landscape has changed yet again big
tech giants such as google amazon
microsoft and facebook are increasingly
sponsoring their own undersea networks
to match their customer needs while
telcos such as at t and bt still operate
or have stakes in dozens of undersea
cables they have long stopped leading
the charge in new and emerging markets
in fact as of 2018 google facebook
amazon and microsoft owned or leased
more than half of all undersea bandwidth
currently google alone owns six active
submarine cables and plans to have eight
more ready within two years while
facebook has stakes in 13 cables as part
owner and is also developing their own
as storage and distribution of content
increases and the old cables laid down
in the 90s slowly approach their
retirement age we are again seeing a
boom in the underseat cable industry but
hang on a second you are probably
thinking what about satellite internet
what about elon's plans with starlink or
facebook's own satellite internet
division isn't that the future of
internet transmission as it turns out it
is not or at least it won't be for the
next few decades there are a few
technical limitations that face the
satellite internet industry which need
to be solved before it can become a
viable option first of all the cost of
launching satellites launch cost still
remains astronomically high second
coverage demands that thousands of mini
satellites be placed into low earth
orbit covering the entire planet such
densely packed constellations will
exacerbate the problems of collisions
and space debris third and final due to
the nature of their orbit not every
satellite will be in reach of a
ground-based antenna all the time this
means that data packets need to be
transmitted from one satellite to the
next until it is in the range of a
ground station satellite to satellite
network hopping this is a technical
challenge that most companies are still
grappling with only starlink has managed
to get the approval of launching 12 000
satellites in low earth orbit and then
again elon has categorically stated that
the company aims to provide internet to
those users who currently do not have
access to high speed fiber thus
underseat cables still remain the most
cost effective and functional solution
for high-speed internet transmission
that's why these tech giants are
investing huge sums of money to lay
newer and faster cables around the globe
but with the incessant march of
technology who knows what the future has
in store for these vast networks under
our oceans what do you think do you
believe that undersea cables are the
future or are they in danger of becoming
obsolete just like the technology
telegraph that spawned it 170 years ago
let us know in the comments section
below thank you for watching
[Music]